hey folks I'm Dave Ramsey I do a talk
radio show called the Dave Ramsey show
we're about 15 to 20 million people join
us every week talking about life and
money our company's Ramsey solutions and
joining me is one of our Ramsey
personalities we call them speaker on
the same stages that I'm on teacher with
me is Chris Vogon number one
best-selling author two times over and
hey we want to talk to those of you that
are CEOs CFOs c-suite errs and those of
you in the HR area today because right
now these are stressful weird and wacky
times your team is freaking out about
their money a lot of you are freaking
out about the stress of just making
payroll we got about a thousand folks on
our team at Ramsey and I got to tell you
over the last several weeks at a time or
two my stomach's been up here right up
next to my throat and we teach you a lot
of stuff on leadership and staying calm
and deliberate and leadership and our
job and leadership we tell our team and
we tell people on teaching leadership is
to serve and that's to take care of our
team and take care of our customers and
I know you feel that same way too and so
there's all kinds of opportunities and
ways to serve right now in the middle of
a pandemic and in the middle of an
economic crisis that made Wharf the
actual medical crisis before it's over
the first thing I want to tell you is
I'm old and I've been through several
things not dissimilar to this things
where we thought the world was coming to
an end things where there was a lot of
drama and I've led through those in
business as a leader and you have to a
lot of you and I got a remind you we're
going to be okay
things are going to change after this
permanently for some of our businesses
and our structures and our delivery
mechanisms we're going to be okay one of
the things we do and probably that we're
best known for at Ramsey is we teach
people how to handle money we teach them
how to get out of debt how to live on a
budget how to have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses and
those that have followed our teaching
including arson
have you know they're sitting there with
an emergency fund right now on no debt
they're pretty thankful and times like
this they really are Dave and you come
to find out having that emergency fund
as a safety net it gives you a cushion
but here's the reality a lot of people
don't know where to begin and how to do
this and that's one of the things that
we've prided ourselves on here at Ramsey
solutions for over 30 years we know the
process and we've got a down pat 78% of
Americans before Quran we're living
paycheck to paycheck
eight out of ten houses on your street
had too much month left at the end of
the money
39% couldn't cover a four hundred dollar
emergency and if they lost their jobs
this week or last week or the week
before they're in real trouble right
this second because they had to
absolutely no margin and they're in a
mess and that's just really most people
and so we've been teaching that group of
people regular humans how to handle
money to not only get prepared for times
like this but to also prosper when
things are going really good these times
are really unprecedented and the
government is throwing a bunch of things
at you right now one of the things I did
is of course they threw a stimulus
package at twelve hundred dollars for
each individual 2,400 for a married
couple $500 per kid and and that's a
nice thing I mean $1200 is helpful but
the truth is 1200 dollars in a lot of
money No and Dave trust me if $1,200
changes your life your life was already
in a tough spot but one of the other
frustrating things they did Dave
throughout that is they allow people to
be able to access their 401k very
dangerous very dangerous the market is
down this is exactly the time to not
take money out of your 401k unless
you're doing it to avoid a bankruptcy or
a foreclosure you need to ride this
market out I've ridden this market a
couple times and nobody gets hurt on a
rollercoaster except those people jump
off in the middle ride baby and so you
need to ride it down ride it up be calm
don't panic no one makes good decisions
when there
anok these are the kinds of messages
were putting out to the public the folks
that work on your teams and even to some
of you to remind you of these things and
yeah we increase the ability to borrow
on the 401k as if that wasn't already a
blight on the 401k program a curse on
that program so now instead of 50,000
now we can borrow a hundred thousand on
it which is a disaster it tears up the
whole baseline of what the whole 401k is
about that's exam so you know these are
the kinds of things you know the
government is throwing stuff at them and
some of it will be somewhat helpful some
of it is just plain reckless and so it's
a problem don't get caught up in this so
just you know we you have to use common
sense you have to keep a cool head in
the middle of these things now here's
the truth you gotta have a plan yes it
works yes Dave it's so very important
you know we tell people and we guide
them but too many times people are
trying to do 10 things at once and it
makes you ineffective all the way around
and so we've got to help people see
clearly dave has taught for years that
you have to take care of the four walls
making sure you're taking care of your
housing your rent or your mortgage
making sure you're taking care of your
utilities and also making sure you have
food on the table but also being able to
have reliable transportation to get you
to and from but Dave you developed a
plan and it's a plan that not only works
but it's changed my life and millions of
lives out there well and it's really not
rocket science but the whole problem
with financial issues is when things are
going well or when they're not you got
all these different options coming at
you do I invest from my 401k do I put
money my kids college fund what about
life insurance
what about paying off this credit card
what about Sallie Mae she's been in my
house so long Shane's our own bedroom
you know we've got all these dadgum
problems coming at us and opportunities
coming at us with money and we don't
know with what to do and so what most
people do is they go them all and they
spend money that's what most people do
and so when in doubt do something stupid
some accrues and it's just and and these
are the folks that depend on you guys
you're giving them the money to live and
they're coming in asking for a raise or
stressed out financially because they
you know Matt you can't get your work
done when Master Card and Discover Card
are calling you through and you know
American distress is on the phone it
just messes up everything and so it
affects productivity at the company it
affects relationships and so the baby
steps plan was to blow the fog off of
all of that and bring great simple
clarity that's when you get that it's
just like oh there's a sense of power
sometimes people call we have you
empowered me well maybe and what you
really had is I didn't you already had
the power I just showed you this is how
this is the shortest distance between
two points this if you want to go to the
beach here's how you get to Florida you
know and here take this road and don't
get off at that exit and don't get off
at that exit it's dangerous and keep
going that's the one you get off and get
your fuel and then you get back on and
the baby steps are a simple seven step
plan we start with a thousand dollars
saved as a beginner start our emergency
fund and then we work off your debt with
the debt snowball everything but your
house listing your debts smallest to
largest paying minimum payments on
everything but the little one and then
when you don't have any payments except
your house then you can go on to baby
step three that's exactly right and this
is where you begin to have some money
saved up for the very first time we
teach people to have three to six months
of expenses sitting in a money market
account
just waiting on life to happen and to
sit there and to be prepared and once
you do that then you move into baby step
four this is where you start to prepare
for your future I'm talking about the
high definition dreams you have down in
your heart you want to invest 15% of
your household income toward retirement
and then Dave you start working on
college yeah and once college is
underway we attack the house and get the
house paid off and then baby step seven
is you are debt-free and there's nothing
left to do but build wealth now here's
what's interesting
Chris had a number one best-selling book
called everyday millionaires and it's
it's the summation of the study of
millionaires in America
that's ever been done here's an
opportunity if you run a company that
you could do for your team what we found
was very simply there were - there's
10,000 millionaires we studied by far
the largest piece of airtight research
ever done on millionaires number one we
found that 90 some odd percent of them
were not millionaires because of
inherited money 79% literally inherited
zero that's right
what we did find though there were two
primary things that caused them if they
had a net worth of under five million
dollars the two primary things that
caused them to be able to become
millionaires your assets minus your
liabilities what you home - what you owe
is your net worth two primary things
that did that and you can help with both
of them and we helped with both up we
sure do Dave the one one of the biggest
things was the number one tool said that
people were investing they were using
employer sponsored retirement plans to
save for the future get this people that
have amassed a net worth of a million
dollars why because of programs that you
all offer that are available to your
team members the second thing was they
paid off their home an average of ten
point two years and some of them doing
it in six or seven years some of them
doing it in 12 or 14 years but they
weren't fooling around with mortgages so
they were getting that house paid off
now here's what's interesting
he took him someone with a net worth of
a million and a half a million of it was
in the company 401k if I own the company
or I was an HR person and someone at our
company became a millionaire because of
our 401k I would be busting with pride
and you should be to learn an
opportunity and you think those folks
are sitting in a different place in the
middle of this crisis I can promise you
they are and the house is completely a
or off Exel maybe step 6
it's amazing hey off the house yes and
so it's a fairly simple thing we find
they had about a $500,000 house and they
had about a million dollars in their
401k a million and a half Network that
was about the ratio every time about
two-thirds to one-third
and so you know three million dollar net
worth is often a two million dollar 401k
Roth IRA package right and about a
million dollar house or maybe a little
piece of real property mixed in there we
saw that time and time and time again so
much so that it became kind of the
persona of the average millionaire now
and the cool thing is is that companies
simply were put in 401k over there now
here's the problem
can't put money in the 401k if you got
student loan debt credit card debt car
payments no budget you and your spouse
aren't in agreement with money and
there's not a clear plan on how to get
there
but if you get all that out of the way
we can set you up where you're putting
fifteen percent away and maybe your
company matches your oh my goodness what
a cool thing
talk about a healing for your team see I
pay out millions and millions of dollars
in payroll to our thousand folks
millions tens of millions of dollars I'd
really like to know that a I'm taking
care of those folks doing a good job for
them loving them well be there working
their butts off getting some work done
because we got to do that around here
too and then see that they get to live
their dreams because they were on our
team and when you do that man it sets up
a whole different reason for HR that's a
whole different reason for this payroll
these aren't just robots were extracting
work out of these are humans with dreams
and we get to be a part of them getting
live that dream Dave I'm so glad to hear
you say that because I want to help you
HR executives and directors of human
resources and c-suite executives really
understand something your team is
counting on you you have an opportunity
to impact their lives in a way like no
one else can you can help guide them you
can help show them what they can do to
help them polish themselves and to
become better and so you have a unique
opportunity to show them that they
matter to you and that you care about
them by helping them work a plan that
actually works and so that sets them up
and times that are rough like this to
make the turn and survive it sets them
up when times are prosperous to prosper
even more
these are the plans that work in good
times and work in bad times they're
God's and grandmas ways of handling
money it used to be called common sense
but it's so rare now common sense is
like having a superpower so we're doing
some different things here at Ramsey and
we've been doing this a long time as a
matter of fact it's fairly easy to make
the statement that the folks at Ramsey
solutions under this brand have gotten
more people out of debt and created more
millionaires with our teachings and then
following our teachings than any other
organization in North America we've been
doing it a long time we're the best
known brand in this space by far we
pretty much invented what you call
financial wellness and so you know we
actually own financial wellness dot-com
so we were there first there's a reason
this is what we do today we got a couple
things we want to give you for free to
help you nothing just give it to you
we're in a position to do that right now
it's a business pivot that we are making
that we've never done before in this
space but we're doing it because of the
wacky weird environment that we're in
right now first if you have had to lay
someone off get in touch with us
immediately and we will make what we
call smart dollar which is our
curriculum that walks them through the
baby steps gets them out of debt gets
them on a budget shows them how to
handle themselves in this situation we
will make smart dollar available to your
laid-off employees for free within the
year that is unprecedented now a smart
dollar being spread out across all the
employees Aldi has taught it to all
their employees through us through their
HR programs Costco has done the same
thing and sonic has done the same thing
so lots of big companies have done this
it's proven successful it's kind of fun
when you and I walk in Costco as a
matter of fact we get high-fives from
the employees because they know us from
the videos teaching them
how to do this and it's very rewarding
to see cashier going Dave I'm getting
out of debt when they're checking me out
there and get my water out the door in
on or whatever it is I'm buying so you
know it's pretty a pretty fun stuff so
if you've had to lay someone off get in
touch with us and we'll give them smart
dollar through the end of the year if
you want to take your current team
through smart daughter we will give you
a free test drive on it we'll give you a
free trial on it and get in touch with
our team and we'll arrange that and we
want you guys to be able to help your
team's during these uncertain times and
they need they need this particular
information right now more than they
need just about anything else as of the
time that Chris and I are sitting here
right now for every single case of
coronavirus in the u.s. over 100 people
have lost their jobs due to the corona
shutdown and so the lots of families are
being impacted on the economic side the
virus side is very scary
we don't know I understand all that I
don't know I'm not a medical person it's
crazy out there but the economic side I
understand and it's crazy out there and
it's affecting actually more people a
hundred more people to the one than the
actual virus itself is affecting today
so those numbers may change but both
unemployment and the virus growth are on
a geometric progression they're on a
curve mathematically so I don't think
those numbers are probably going to
change the ratio is going to change much
so we have the opportunity to serve our
teams right now and we're giving you the
tools free a free test drive for your
current team members and smart dollar
for your laid off folks through the end
of the year completely completely free
the way you do that you go to smart
dollar comm slash hope and everything
you need to get started is right there
our team will get in touch with you
depending on the size of your business
we'll get your categorize and prioritize
we'll get you in a slot and we'll get
you and your team and even your former
team taken care of if I was unemployed
and my
employer called me and said hey we want
to show you how to help with your money
now some of them might be angry or
bitter right and they might not react
well to that but most people would just
be straight-up grateful oh absolutely
Dave that's not anything that anyone
ever does so you've got an opportunity
to be different to be that kind of
company that actually cares about the
people on your team
and I want you to hear me you've
probably heard the word wellness before
and you've seen some products out there
there's a lot of programs that involve
people going into debt not getting out
of it so I want you to understand
something smart dollar is different Dave
myself and Rachel Cruise are all
teaching we engage people because we
care about people and so you're gonna
have an opportunity to help your team
learn about money like they never have
before
so let me tell you what real financial
wellness is it's when someone's finances
become well because they learned how to
handle them it's not a payday lender
come on there's some trash out there
coming in under this heading and it
needs to stop we're teachers that's all
we are we're not here to sell them
something
we're not here to slick them we're not
here to fleece them or just teaching
them and that's real financial wellness
folks just need hope right now they need
a plan and an ambiguity not knowing will
drive you nuts and if you've got a plan
in your personal life you've got a plan
in your business for what's going to
happen with revenue changes you got a
plan in your business what's going to
happen with the expense changes in the
middle of this craziness then you've got
a sense of peace that the people who are
disconnected and floating in their
anxiety just do not have our mission at
Ramsey's just to help people transform
their lives to help people have hope
that's real not some kind of false
positive thinking that you know guru
think but instead here's a plan follow
this plan if you plant corn corn will
grow if you plant corn corn will grow as
you sow so shall you reap it is really
not rocket science you've just got to do
this stuff and it's an opportunity for
you to love your people well and we're
giving it to you free
I mean what else do we need to do so get
in touch with us at smart dollar comm
slash hope thank you guys for being in
the chairs you're in right now for
leading with the courage you're leading
with and for holding American business
together this is the greatest country
the world has ever known and the other
side of coronaviruses still will be